ça va ya un gros cadeau vous allez
ouvrir un énorme cadeau à notre ami
benjamin castaldi
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer mes
chroniqueurs de talent et matthieu
delormeau aura également merci
tel un cadeau mais on n'a pas le temps
long terme si tu pouvais le gâteau c'est
une enceinte une enceinte bluetooth
j'imagine ayant la possibilité non
seulement de le conserver ou new look
changer contre les deux rideaux il est
bon dis-moi tu te fous de ma gueule par
courrier à la fin c'est jour pour kelly
aujourd'hui elle enceinte au barreau on
est juste en fonction de la personne que
l'on voit avec qui tu as dormi à disney
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est benjamin casse tête
il ya le rideau rouge le rideau bleu
frais est ce que vous voulez tout de
suite éliminer un rideau je vais passer
le rideau éliminer ou bien vous pouvez
me dire je garde le cadeau je gardais en
simple mais vous connaissez vous êtes
très joueurs non non je savais faire
trop on peut facilement de crem que de
cadeaux voilà alors non je vais c'est
dingue parce que en fait il est banni
mais il est autoalimenté le mec là alors
maintenant je vais éliminer le rideau
rouge le rouge
ouais
[Musique]
c'est bien
interverti seul cadeau
[Applaudissements]
on va tout de suite voir ce qui se
cachait derrière le rideau rouge
benjamin castaldi nous avons enlevé le
rideau rouge
jamais donc ce cadeau sera pas bons
procédés
ce genre besoin d'eux ça sent la
attendez vous avez limiter le rayon ou
la wii c'est vraiment l'ascenseur
émotionnel alors dans le top des prix
mais savoir l'assistance ou pl oui tu
veux moi non ça là bas ils sont en train
d'échanger
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne change plus ça fait rire fausses
solutions mais surtout moi ta caisse
vous prenez ben chez ces primates en
voilà c'est un cadeau que vous gardez
donc mené les bills élimine le rouge je
prends le bel 20 des ménages les sabres
bien sûr gardent leur calme et
comprennent rien alors le raja ma
vaisselle rideau tu choisis je les avais
dit j'élimine le rouge je prends le bleu
motifs armes et l'argent et le temps de
crise et 20 fois en plus donc un [ __ ]
le connaît à nos débuts t'ai pas dit
rouge c'est bon tu tu as l'air d'être
après dollars l'escroc problème ils sont
bons vous et moi tes chiens non non non
je vous montrais si vous avez perdu
ah oui vous avez perdu vos savoirs
castaldi un un cadre avec tout vos ex
femme
[Applaudissements]
mercredi
il n'est battu que l'armée y aller nous
ressasser ça c'est bien qu'il ya régine
si ça s'est perdu ce que vous avez gagné
ça me ça me manquera pas gagné c'est un
très beau cadeau
benjamin vous savez que je vous aime
énormément et que ce soit jamais envie
de vous faire un cadeau exceptionnel à
ce que à personnage exceptionnel cadeau
exceptionnel auquel mélo benjamin
castaldi il ya derrière ce rideau bleu
alors on pouvait me dire voilà je garde
l'enceinte
non non non non je prends le rideau bleu
derrière le rideau bleu et jaune au
chili à un cadeau explique benjamin
il y a il y à une femme une femme
exceptionnelle room c'est peut-être une
de vos ex arrêté qui est là un tout la
vie si ces engrais à la voyante
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous landréat canadair x ou y
rester en plus toutes les missions dès
que vous avez des prédictions n'hésitez
pas là